[Music]
how do we humans perceive the things
around us we have five senses that help
us to interact with the world around us
these are sight hearing taste smell and
touch eyes help us to see things years
help us to hear sounds we smell with our
nose taste with our tongue and a sense
of touch is provided by our skin of
course all senses are important but the
sense of sight is the most important
here is an interesting fact we perceive
almost 80% of the world around us by
using our sense of sight we see objects
around us with our eyes but then why
don't our eyes see these objects in the
dark the answer to this question is
light we are able to see the objects
around us because of the light coming
from these objects the light from these
objects travels in space and reaches our
eyes when it's dark or during night time
as there is no light we are unable to
see these objects clearly some objects
can generate their own light
for instance the Sun the fluorescent
bulbs burning candles can generate their
own light the objects which generate
their own light are called the luminous
objects almost all of the objects that
we come across cannot generate their own
light the table a chair wall paper a few
of such examples such objects are called
as non luminous objects but I just told
you that we see objects around us
because of the light coming from them
and if objects like these cannot
generate light then how come we're able
to see them we are able to see them
because of the reflection of light these
objects reflect the light to our eyes
what light are they reflecting where is
the light coming from this light is
nothing but the light coming from the
luminous objects so how can we summarize
this for you're able to see Nalu
objects because they reflect the light
of the luminous objects falling on these
surfaces let me repeat the light coming
from the luminous objects falls on the
non luminous objects non luminous
objects then reflect this light and this
reflected light travels towards our eyes
and that's why we see the objects in the
daytime we are able to see blue skies
the white clouds and the green grass
because the light from the Sun is
getting reflected by them and traveling
towards our eyes at night we are able to
see the moon because it is reflecting
the light from the Sun note that moon is
non luminous and it cannot generate its
own light as I said earlier most of the
objects that we come across in our daily
life are non luminous we only see them
because they reflect the light step
inside a dark room light up a torch and
point it at the distant wall look
carefully at the path of the light
coming from the torch you will see tiny
dust particles in the air what does the
reason for this
why are you able to see these particles
you are able to see the dust particles
because the light from the torch is
getting reflected from their surfaces
and travelling towards our eyes we also
see the same thing in a very dimly lit
room where the only source of light is a
small amount of sunlight coming from the
window in this video we saw that the
reflection of light plays an important
role it's because of the reflection of
light that we are able to see most of
the objects in the next video we will
talk about the laws of reflection of
light
[Music]